war in afghanistan was never meant to be
a multi-generational undertaking
we were attacked we went to war with
clear goals
we achieved those objectives bin laden
is dead
and al qaeda is degraded in afghanistan
and it's time to end the forever war
when i'm sleeping i see war you're
expecting
to be killed anytime we have to like be
strong we only have each other
thanks to our military and our allies
and the brave fighters of afghanistan
the taliban regime is coming to an end
[Applause]
i saw everyone was smiling and i saw the
people with the shaved beds
i was surprised that what the hell is
going on when i came home and i asked my
father and my ankles
so that's because they're showing their
happiness and then they're showing also
they're
disgusting from the taliban that they
were making people to
grow beards but here this host
for them
the americans lost two and a half
thousand regular troops and another
three and a half thousand what they call
private contractors but essentially
they're there
uh doing military type stuff and then
the nato allies who went in with the
united states
lost well over a thousand troops with
450 british troops amongst them
perhaps inevitably the main casualties
were taken by
afghans themselves something like 66 000
afghan troops killed over 40 000 afghan
civilian dead
and indeed there are now so many
different attacks there's a constant
drumbeat of small atrocities i'm afraid
now happening in afghanistan
well my name is abdullah i'm 20 years
old
i was born in 2001. my mother's name
is cadria yossini she was
murdered by a terrorist group
so this is the portrait drawn by my
brother
so that we can remember her by this
picture
and this is the handbag
she was carrying during that attack
there are some bullet holes in these
parts
there are some bullet holes
in this particular ladder too
and we wrote this on the mother's day to
her to our surprise
she kept it for uh for i think two years
which shows how much she cared about us
and how much she was kind
once you get into the whole business of
nation building it becomes potentially
endless it's not just securing the
cities
but also trying to reconstruct the army
trying to reconstruct the economy
eradicating the drug trade trying to
improve rights for women
so you do get this incredible mission
creep but ultimately the reason they
stayed 20 years
was that they never really felt that
they had completely suppressed
the taliban and therefore the risk of
islamist terrorism
coming back and they still haven't
i must say that i'm super impressed and
proud of my people
with the transformation that we have
made in the just two decades as a
society
and as citizens we liberated the avon
people especially afron woman
you see thousands and millions of girls
going to school despite of security
threats that we have
you see many women that they have
started business they are activists they
are working in media
and all of us are trying to rebuild our
country
we demonstrated to the afghan citizen
that they can also have a better life
my name is mina karemi i'm 16 years old
and i'm a musician
cello have really deep sound and
i i think with cello i can express
things that i couldn't with the like
words
with the music we can show our pain our
happiness like our joy like everything
my mother always support me but my
father
was a little bit worried my father was
at first like
she's just a girl she can go just for
one year then
she would be like olden and she wouldn't
go my relatives saw me
in the like in the shows like some
concerts and then they start telling my
parents that your daughter is into music
they start disturbing my family and my
family would always say
nah that's not my daughter so like
because
they were really against music so that's
why my family would
tell them like that to protect me and my
neighbors was really against it so
my family decided to send me to my mom's
friend's house and i left with her
for three years
[Music]
as afron woman when you decide to
be active outside the family or even
inside the family if you want to be part
of decision making
it's not easy because simply the
perception that people are having is
that you're a woman
and as long as you're supported and
you're provided with the basic needs of
life why you have to bother about other
issues
i'll give you one simple example
whenever we are invited
to a meeting by the authorities or by
the international community
they prefer to talk to us about women's
issues
about women's rights and about women
engagement and different processes in
the country
they never talk to us about issues such
as the peace process itself
the political situation the rampant
corruption what could be the solution
for the current conflict that we have in
afghanistan somehow they think that
those
issues are big and serious issues that
they need to discuss with the main
this is my first camera and i worked
nine months in a tyler shop to buy this
my name is masood hussaini i grew up in
iran
but i i was born in afghanistan in kabul
i'm a photo journalist
even in the war zone the life is going
on
it was important for me to show
happiness
sadness and everything all together
[Music]
so it was 2007 it was eid in afghanistan
and it was hopeful years for afghanistan
and we really thought that we are
going to be like a normal
country in the world well actually i saw
this girl
really happy and with the great dresses
those years girls and women were coming
out of the houses i mean slowly
so i took that picture and it was
a symbol of the hope symbol of freedom
symbol of the young generation in
afghanistan for me
my name is nasar ahmad i have done too
many jobs in afghanistan
especially working with the native
forces
as interpreter then i came and joined
afghan
commanders
people around me they were saying his
son is going to university
so he's enjoying his life he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about his family
sorry for using powers
that made me a bit crazy and i thought i
supposed to
help my family to make some money
and also that's a good help for the
african army
from the cultural side that i can show
the foreigners that they came from
another culture and they don't know the
afghan one
and i heard from the other people that
being an interpreter especially in
helmand province
it's a bit weird because uh
that's a dangerous place and especially
when the
taliban cuts and tempera there would
slay or they would cut the head off
it was a bit hard for me thinking about
that
[Music]
i clicked and then explosion happened
and
when the smoke came down i saw that i'm
standing in this
big circle of all dead and destroyed
bodies
so i start taking picture when i was
crying
it was a big shock you know my uh
heart was bit beating even more than
200.
i knew that it might be another attack
or it might be another danger
because i was trained as a war
photographer but i
i decided to stay uncovered because i
was the only one
there and when i get in front of her
i saw that she's trying to tell me
something
but my ear wasn't less couldn't hear
anything
because of the explosion and i put my
camera down for a second
and i told another person that she's
saying something
she's telling something she was pointing
another boy
in front of her legs so uh
the man left the boy
and the boy the backside of the head was
completely destroyed
and he told me that this boy is dead
she start screaming a lot
screaming
after two three days when i was checking
my photos
i saw that i was standing exactly at the
place that the suicide attacker sat on
the ground and explored himself
these photos are reminding me when i was
signing in a
front line always expecting a bullet
memories from the friends
that i was with and now they're not
they're no more existing in this world
they are tired they're killed by taliban
after a bit of time i heard the
television sound on the radio
and they were costing us you son of bush
or son of obama if you are a good man if
you're a brave man so come and face me
so i had nomination i started crying
there
because of the person that got killed
there because of the army
i started crying because of
[Music]
the weakness that we had there i said
okay
if it's going like this i don't want to
kill my personal
i don't want to hand over the tanks and
the weapons to taliban
if you have nomination against your
enemy
you're nothing that's why i left it
like i run away i do not lift i did not
ask them that i'm
leaving my job i went away
my mother was one of the few women's
that were a judge my mom believed that
women's are not just created to work in
home but they have a destiny to change
the world too
i for sure know that she was the best
example
for me for my brother for my family and
we will always follow her footsteps
well i was i was eating my breakfast
when my neighbor called me he wanted to
ask for my mother's
number it's kind of weird to ask for
someone's mother's number
uh we were kind of terrified and asked
the reason
they just didn't want to tell us and
in an hour or so my uncle called me
and said that in her way to work they
attacked her car
with guns i was in kind of
shocked i said my uncle to shut up
it's it's a lie i even screamed at her
at him
but he said it's something that happened
there's no changing that
the supreme court proposed for her to
get a gun for her defense but she
rejected
we didn't believe that there will be any
threat to her
because she was not hurting anyone
she was not taking any side in a
political climate and
we didn't know that such a thing would
happen but
i guess we were wrong
if an attack that's happening in
afghanistan would happen to any other
country but afghanistan
you would see that people would talk
about it for days
you would see that the countries are
going to lower their flag
half to just share the pain of and
suffering of that nation
there is going to be emergency meeting
in the united nations
but the violence and the killing has
become so normal in afghanistan
nobody is even bothering to talk about
it because they think that that's very
normal in afghanistan it's happening on
daily basis
this whole question of winning the war
brought back echoes of vietnam
initially there was this hope that you
would totally dismantle the taliban and
al qaeda
and then it gets to sort of suppress
them and then it sort of gets into well
let's try to sort of create a
functioning afghan society
and now again in another echo of vietnam
there's this horrible fear
that uh the us and its allies will pull
out
and perhaps at some point the taliban
will return not just to
you know large sways of the countryside
but even to kabul itself
in an echo of the fall of saigon in
1975.
when i was in my car so they were just
shooting from both sides
the bullets were going from here both
this way to that way
[Music]
i thought that the war
would be finished in 2010 or 2011
and then the rest i will record peace
i will record a smile of children woman
everything would be great but it didn't
happen
i spent best years of the life
taking the war pictures taking um
violence trying to show that what is bad
but nothing is changed
i'm also disappointed i was wounded
11 time and i
escaped the life 11 time right
only for my country for my people
destroying my own mentality when i'm
sleeping i see war when i'm out
i see war when i'm here i see dead
bodies
and i always suffer so many many times i
receive the threats that they tell me
that your
name is nonetheless you're in the
headless they use kaffar kapha means
infidel
means the one with no religion says your
son has worked with kaffar if we could
him
we're gonna kill him your car is this
model
the number is this model you go and meet
these friends and because you are
against islamic emirates of afghanistan
and you're trying to bring the ideas and
culture of the west
into afghanistan our court
kind of like finalized to kill you
[Music]
to execute you there are times that i
work from home for weeks
uh because of that those threats right
now probably is
three months that i don't go
much out and if i go i do not take my
car
i try to bike when it's dark
i decided to leave the country i thought
it might be the safest place
to live outside of afghanistan
[Music]
means for each person his own homeland
is uh
paradise for him i ended up to
here from a shitty place
named camp moya
so i'm quite happy here
i i believe the american people
understand that we have got a mighty
struggle on our hands
and that there will be sacrifice
america's war
in afghanistan will come to a
responsible end we're coming back we're
almost finished
we're pulling finally these endless
wards
i've concluded that it's time to end
america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home i think he feels very personally
that you can't take the lives and the
service of these american soldiers for
granted
but there's also a geopolitical thing
the united states over the last decade
has become increasingly preoccupied by
the rise of china
biden and even actually before him the
people in the trump administration
see this as the defining challenge for
the united states
and increasingly they see conflicts like
the one in afghanistan or even syria
as a distraction as something that where
they
will waste resources not just financial
but even if you like
mental amounts of time they spend
thinking about this thing the risk
is increase in violence
taliban becoming more aggressive the
states that they are sponsoring taliban
might provide
more uh resources to the taliban for
intensifying the fight on top of that
we see limitations on the side of our
national security forces
we also see the organizations of the
different militias in different parts of
afghanistan
that actually will begin to join the
fight against the taliban
for protecting their community so as a
result slowly and gradually we will be
moving towards civil war which is going
to be
absolutely bloody how much is
you will see that with determination
with unity
and with the partnership we will
overcome all odds thank you
thank you i thought that they betrayed
us if they didn't come here
and they just bombed and go and take and
arrest
osama bin laden and wouldn't touch my
life or other people life
come to afghanistan built a lot of
things uh i change a lot of people's
dream and make a lot of other new dream
for the young people
that was much much better
[Music]
i was two years when the conflict starts
in afghanistan
and we are still in that conflict all we
see
is uh intimidation
violence and injustice and impunity
so for us the model where you see that
the communities are living in harmony
with each other
they are trying to resolve their
disputes peacefully with each other
as as a model that we have not
experienced in afghanistan
they spent a lot of money for a weapon
for a lot of other things
but they never tried to change the
culture
they never tried to create the
idea of peace so it means that they
didn't want peace
happening here we have dog fightings we
have
coke fightings we have birth fightings
we have
everything fighting here for sure that
we should change this culture
this is not a good culture right people
are using a lot of
violence against each other we needed to
change that
we needed to bring the youth
and make them busy with arts
[Music]
so i composed a piece named don
and it's about struggles of women and
the problems that they faced in past and
the
problems that they're facing right now
the name is don
because now um it's like done and
all the women's are standing for their
rights and fighting for
their rights to achieve it
[Music]
yeah it's not finished because we are
still fighting for
our rights in afghanistan
when we like achieve all of our rights
in afghanistan
i'll definitely finish it like in the
really
happy ending
[Music]
it's about four decades of war in
afghanistan
like even if you ask kid what do you
need in your country they will ask
peace well the situations
these days are really really bad but
like we have to like be strong in this
all these times because we only have
each other it's like we afghans have
each other
the change always starts from small
things but grow to
bigger things i still think that there
is
going to be hope there is going to be a
change
and i think afghanistan will get better
and one day we will experience the
freedom
that every other country has and i
really hope
for that day to arrive that
will be a dream come true
you